what do Post-it notes blood sucking
fiends and stand-up comedians have in
common they're all part of a larger
puzzle that when pieced together might
explain why the real life Mark with a
mouth said nighty night to a certain
daywalker Ryan Reynolds has sat at the
top of the Hollywood heat for many years
now taking on all kinds of projects in
that time from goofy comedies to
superhero ethics he has proven himself
an immensely versatile on-screen talent
in doing so Reynolds has brushed
shoulders with numerous fellow big
screen stars from Hugh Jackman to his
wife Blake Lively While most of these
cinematic Partnerships turned out to be
pretty fruitful not all of them left
Reynolds eager to reunite with his
co-star and future features down the
road
don't make the same mistakes I did got
it long before he brought Deadpool to
Life For the First Time Reynolds made
his Marvel movie debut in 2004's blade
Trinity in the role of Hannibal King he
stands beside blade himself played by
Wesley Snipes as they battle back
against the vampires who seek to
terrorize Humanity though they work
together Hannibal and blade are far from
France which seems Samira Reynold's real
life strange relationship with Snipes
when asked by Premiere magazine if he'd
ever worked with Snipes again on a
potential blade four Reynolds made it
clear with a slight laugh and a shake of
his head that he has no interest he into
account what Reynolds has said about his
experience working with Snipes on blade
Trinity it's no surprise that he doesn't
want to work with the actor again it has
long been the word online that Wesley
Snipes wasn't the easiest to work with
on the set of Blade Trinity
the actor supposedly remained in his
trailer for most of the shoot emerging
only to film close-ups thus leaving his
stand-ins to do the bulk of the work
over the years other stories like him
only communicating with director David S
goyer solely through Post-it notes
attempting to choke him out at one point
and refusing to open his eyes for one
scene have gained a lot of traction on
the internet give he would communicate
with with uh Post-its that he would give
to the director and each one he would
sign blade his interactions with Ryan
Reynolds have also made the rounds
somewhat explaining Reynolds disinterest
in working with Snipes again after
stating that many of the claims
regarding the tension between himself
and Snipes are overblown Reynolds were
called to IGN my personality is the
polar opposite of Wesley I never met
Wesley I only met blade and he is a
method actor he added that he respects
Snipes for his method approach to the
character and his commitment to the
craft but he could tell that his co-star
couldn't stand him noting that his
ad-living seemed to get on snipe's
nerves he continued there's a moment in
the movie where I look up at Jessica
Biel and I swear to God I didn't even
know the cameras were rolling anymore
and I say he hates me doesn't he and
she's like yeah he hates me doesn't he
yeah unsurprisingly as the many Blade
Trinity rumors centered on him have
picked up steam Wesley Snipes has taken
it upon himself to set the record
straight in some regards when it comes
to his Post-It note usage long trips to
his trailer and clashes with David S
goyer these points stemming from
comedian and blade Trinity actor Pat
Oswalt he asserted during a chat with
the guardian that these supposed
anecdotes from the set Are Nothing More
Than Fiction in the aforementioned
interview Snipes didn't bring up Ryan
Reynolds his feelings on his frequent
improv or anything regarding their time
working opposite one another on the
third blade belt instead he focused
primarily on Oswald's comments and their
wider implications therefore it's safe
to assume that the actor hopes to put
Blade Trinity his experience working on
it and all the rumors and stories
surrounding its troubled production
behind him after all the three cool is
rapidly approaching 20 years old and
both he and Reynolds have moved on
personally and professionally
hello hello
[Music]